tf1 20 heures avec jean claude bourret
le défilé du 14 juillet vous verrez ce
que les parisiens n'ont pas vu à cause
des nuages la revue aérienne au dessus
de la capitale dans une interview
monsieur giscard d'estaing rend hommage
aux forces armées et évoque son prochain
voyage dans le pacifique en quarts à un
document bouleversant sur la mort de
l'un des otages de l'ambassade d'égypte
les dirigeants palestiniens vont essayer
de relancer la négociation
rugby le festival du quinze tricolore en
nouvelle-zélande avec les quatre essais
marqués contre les all-blacks automobile
clay regazzoni remporte le grand prix
d'angleterre à silverstone
rené arnoux et second jean pierre jarier
troisième enfin luis ocaña techniciens
d'antenne de james arasa grièvement
blessé dans un accident de voiture cet
après midi aux ménuires madame
mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir il y avait
de gros nuages ce matin sur la région
parisienne pour le défilé du 14 juillet
se fut dommage car le défilé aérien déjà
réduit pour des raisons d'économies n'a
pas été visible ni pour les parisiens
venus fort nombreux entre la bastille et
la république ni pour les millions de
téléspectateurs qui ont suivi le défilé
en direct sur tf1
mais ce soir nous vous proposons une
petite compensation une caméra de tf1
étaient à bord de l'un des avions un
breguet atlantique qui est passé avec
les autres appareils dans le ciel de
paris
mais au dessus des nuages avant de
découvrir ces images tournées par oc
pescadère michel en fois les alain
rodier nous résume les grands moments de
ce défi des 8000 hommes à pied 300
cavaliers 350 véhicules et 80 avions ont
participé à ce défilé ouvert comme le
veut la tradition par l'école
polytechnique à la garde du drapeau deux
des 16 jeunes filles appartenant à cette
promotion 1977 des femmes aussi
et uniquement des femmes ici dans ce
détachement de l'école interarmées des
personnels féminins
créé en 1973
deux unités d'outre-mer invité le
régiment d'infanterie de marine de fort
de france est ici un détachement du
régiment du service militaire adapté de
guyane qui en plus des tâches militaires
effectuent des grands travaux ainsi que
de la formation professionnelle dans les
dom tom
présent aussi les réservistes qui pour
l'occasion ont reformé un détachement du
24e régiment d'infanterie de paris et
puis voici le plus ancien régiment de
france puisque le 1er régiment
d'infanterie de sarrebourg est issu des
bandes de picardie formé en 14 179 par
louis on venait ensuite le 40e régiment
d'artillerie présentant pour la première
fois un canon de 155 automoteurs à
grande cadence de tir et à ses pièces
d'impressionnantes succédé les matériels
de la 11ème division parachutiste de
toulouse tout d'abord c'est jeep équipée
de missiles antichars milan puis des
véhicules lors servant aux troupes
aéroportées un matériel parachute table
de conception rustique est capable de
gravir des pentes de 50%
enfin une large présentation des
systèmes d'armes crotales de la base
d'istres une arme entièrement
automatisée contre les avions
supersoniques volant à basse altitude
détection et tire en quelques secondes
c'était là les points forts d'une revue
que devait ouvrir un grand défilé aérien
mais les spectateurs n'en virent que
l'avant-garde les neuf fouga magister de
la patrouille de france
nuages oblige
en effet pendant que nous regardions les
nuages place de la bastille rock
pescadère facettes avec sa caméra mais
sans nous voir au dessus de nos têtes
aborde un breguet atlantique
le jour n'était pas encore levé sur la
base de lann bihoué
lorsque la flottille 23f de l'aéronavale
prenez l'air en direction d'orléans la
tâche habituelle de recherche océanique
de surveillance des zones côtières ou de
lutte anti-sous-marine été remplacé ce
matin par un rendez vous avec les
transall de la base de bricy jusqu'aux
abords de la région parisienne le ciel
était dégagé la visibilité est
excellente mais les choses se gâtaient
en approchant d'orléans
les huit transall c160 du commandement
du transport aérien a gardé l'espoir et
voler vers paris précédent les quatre
ans régalent atlantique les alpha jet de
l'école de chasse de tours étaient
passés peu auparavant mais sans succès à
1300 pieds soit 400 m le plafond est
encore trop bas et tout le défilé s'est
déroulé une façon très simple la foule
n'apercevait pas les avions cachée par
les nuages mais les entendez les pilotes
eux ne voyait pas le sol et n'entendait
que leurs moteurs les habitants des
banlieues est paris furent plus heureux
ils purent non seulement entendre mais
voir tous les 80 appareils
le président valéry giscard d'estaing a
exprimé au ministre de la défense
monsieur yvon bourges son entière
satisfaction pour la remarquable
organisation et l'excellente tenue des
unités qui ont participé aux cérémonies
du 14 juillet à paris le président de la
république s'est ensuite rendu à
l'elysée où 4000 personnalités avaient
été invités à 13h lorsque monsieur
giscard d'estaing est apparu sur le
perron de l'elysée la foule compacte des
4000 invités lui a fait une ovation
dans l'assistance des femmes et des
hommes connus mais aussi des françaises
et des français qui se sont distingués
lors de l'année écoulée
un reportage de patrick de carolis à
cette réception
traditionnelle revue militaire
traditionnelle réception fer par le
président de la république il est 11
heures le défilé est terminée valéry
giscard d'estaing regagner l'elysée
une demi heure plus tard plus de 4000
invités salueront le chef de l'état en
tête les membres du gouvernement le
président de l'assemblée nationale le
président du sénat les corps
diplomatique le maire de paris mais
aussi les membres de l'académie
française et quelques personnalités du
spectacle
en fait en feuilletant la liste les
invités on s'aperçoit qu'une grande
place a été réservée l'actualité cette
réception est temps pour le président de
la république l'occasion de nouveaux
contacts
on a remarqué la présence de nombreux
maires il faut dire qu'on parle beaucoup
des collectivités locales parmi les
invités également des gendarmes des
pompiers bénévoles des médecins sans
frontières et quelques personnes
originaires des dom tom en vue du voyage
qui effectuera le président de la
république en polynésie
le chef de l'état bien sûr n'a pas
oublié les sportifs sur la pelouse de
l'elysée on a beaucoup parlé transat
avec eric tabarly riguidel gilles
gahinet marc pajot florence arthaud et
malinowski le président valéry giscard
d'estaing a reçu son premier colliers de
fleurs des mains d'une ravissante
tahitienne à la veille de son départ
pour tahiti
le président de la république entre en
effet un grand voyage dans les
territoires et départements français
d'outre-mer du bout du monde
le président giscard d'estaing a
expliqué pour quelles raisons le défilé
du 14 juillet n'avait pas eu lieu sur
les champs elysées cette année il était
important at il dit que la fête
nationale à ceux ci successivement les
différents quartiers de paris
l'année prochaine le défilé retrouvera
l'avenue des champs elysées et puis le
chef de l'état a confié à paul amar
d'antenne 2 et à patrice duhamel son
sentiment sur le niveau de notre défense
nationale
je crois qu'on peut dire que notre
défense est actuellement bon état c'est
le résultat d'ailleurs d'un effort
efforts d'organisation efforts de
commandement et fort d'entraînement et
en même temps mise à la disposition de
notre défense des moyens dont elle avait
besoin notamment des moyens financiers
et à cet égard je veux dire que le
gouvernement dans ses propositions le
parlement dans ses votes ont permis au
cours des dernières années de donner à
notre défense les moyens nécessaires
et je dirais que d'un seul coup d'oeil
on en voit le résultat à la fois dans la
tenue de nos forces et en même temps
dans les moyens matériels dont ils
disposent et peux vous dire que cet
effort sera poursuivi en 1981 nous avons
examiné cette semaine avec le premier
ministre ennemi de la défense la
question du niveau des ressources
consacrées à la défense en 1981 celle ci
permettront la poursuite de
l'amélioration de notre système de
défense président vous partez de
m'asseoir pour un long voyage des
milliers de kilomètres vous allez
visiter un certain nombre de territoires
d'outre-mer noumea wallis et futuna
c'est ici polynésie l'étoile vous tous
alors pourquoi ce voyage les territoires
d'outre-mer et que direz vous à ces
français du lointain sur la situation
générale de la france en cette
mi-juillet 79/100 pourquoi ce voyage
c'est parce que ces territoires font
partie de la république française qui
l'ont d'ailleurs rappelé récemment ne
serait ce que par les élections qui
viennent d'avoir lieu en nouvelle
calédonie et donc dans les
responsabilités du président de la
république il y à celle d'aller rendre
visite à ces territoires qui font partie
de la république française et dont le
président est président au même titre
que vis-à-vis de tous les autres en
france est le dernier pays dans la
politique soit à laisser le général de
gaulle qui était allé en 1966 il ya donc
13 ans et il était normal que le pédant
la plus française à leur rendre visite
en même temps c'est pour moi l'occasion
de faire le point de la situation de ces
territoires
point de la situation politique après le
très grand effort de décentralisation
qui est incomplet au cours des dernières
années de façon à mettre à la population
et à ses élus d'exercer davantage de
responsabilités dans le cadre de la
gestion de leurs propres affaires et en
même temps développement économique de
ces territoires fait qu'ils ont souffert
vous avez de la crise et qu'il faut donc
examiner avec eux le moyen d'améliorer
leur développement économique et social
et le langage que je parlerai sera le
langage de la fraternité et de l'égalité
vous avez pu suivre dans notre journal
de 13h l'intégralité de l'interview
accordée antenne 2 et à tf1 par monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing la fête du 14
juillet continue ce soir en france avec
de nombreux feux d'artifice et bal
populaire à 22h35 sur tf1 tout à l'heure
en direct de la conte
horn vous pourrez suivre un spectacle
imaginé par jean michel jarre et
commenté par claude dufresne de nombreux
messages de chefs d'état étrangers ont
été adressées à l'elysée à l'occasion de
notre fête nationale
une fête que les français de l'étranger
ont célébré avec des moyens parfois
modeste mais toujours avec beaucoup de
coeur est l'un des 14 juillet les plus
émouvants a été celui des forces
françaises engagées sous la bannière de
paix de l'onu au liban
un reportage de notre envoyé spécial au
liban julien galeotti la torah au sud
liban
ici au poste de commandement de la finul
les 600 parachutistes commandé par le
colonel mathieu ont fêté le 14 juillet
en présence du général nigérien air skin
commandant la finul norvégien irlandais
sénégalais fidjiens et les palais sont
venus assister en voisin à ce défilé
modeste mais qui est impressionnant dans
cette zone déserte à quatre kilomètres
d'israël et où chaque jour les
israéliens bombardent la région
environnante de tir un défilé du 14
juillet dans un camp encerclé par les
mises chrétienne du major haddad qui
contrôle la seule route qui va vers
beyrouth et en profite pour réclamer aux
voitures qui passent quelques livres
libanaises et malgré cette situation peu
confortable
un défilé des parachutistes qui par leur
présence avec les 5000 hommes de la
finul sont actuellement la seule force
militaire qui empêche un nouvel
affrontement sud liban un 14 juillet
samba descend feu d'artifice ne serait
pas une vraie fête est ici à plus de
3000 km de la france on danse aussi sous
les lampions et les fusées éclairantes
en pensant 14 juillet du pays avec
nostalgie à ankara le gouvernement turc
que vient de publier un communiqué nous
ferons tout notre possible pour mettre
fin à la prise d'otages dans l'ambassade
d'egypte
sans qu'il y ait davantage d'effusion de
sang depuis hier un commando de quatre
palestiniens détient 16 personnes dont
l'ambassadeur d'égypte lors de la prise
de l'ambassade par le commando hier deux
policiers ont été abattus et ce matin un
homme a trouvé la mort un autre a été
grièvement blessé tous deux en tombant
du 4e étage dans des conditions mal
définie on ne sait pas en effet si l'on
sauté volontairement ce qui semble être
le cas lorsque l'on regarde le film de
leur chute aussi quelqu'un frapper sur
leurs mains pendant qu ils s'agrippaient
au montant de la fenêtre
je souligne pour les personnes sensibles
que les images que nous allons diffuser
maintenant sont particulièrement durs un
commentaire de jean loup de milieu
encerclé par les blindés de la police
turque l'ambassade d'egypte boulevard
atatürk l'artère principale d'ankara
l'occupation de l'ambassade a commencé
hier matin elle est le fait d'un
commando des aigles de la révolution
palestinienne
une organisation qui n'a rien à voir
avec l'ol paie l'organisation de
libération de la palestine ce matin à
l'aube
deux des sept otages ont donc réussi à
s'enfuir par une fenêtre du
rez-de-chaussée un peu plus tard deux
autres otages ont essayé d'en faire
autant mais cette fois la 4e étage avec
moi une chance pareille cet homme n'a
pas pu contrôler sa chute il va mourir
treize secondes plus tard après avoir
jeté un oeil sur mon camarade au sol
l'autre homme va souper mais six ans
auparavant être légèrement déséquilibré
son hurlement prévient les policiers que
lui et vivant alors des chars vont
s'approcher de l'ambassade
ils vont essayer de parvenir le plus tôt
possible des deux corps pour les
protéger les dires possible depuis le 4e
étage de l'ambassade des lances à eau
sous très forte pression sont là pour
dissuader les membres du commando
palestinien s'approcher des fenêtres
pendant ce temps un policier va quitter
l'un des blindés pour aider les
survivants à saisir un drap grâce auquel
les policiers vont attirer dans leur
véhicule
si vous regardez bien cette image vous
verrez que l'homme se sert encore de ses
jambes aux facilités sont français
12 otages sont toujours prisonniers dans
l'ambassade d'égypte à ankara le
gouvernement turc a mis en place un
état-major de crise une délégation
palestinienne est arrivé ce matin en
syrie vont participer à la négociation
le gouvernement égyptien de son côté
semble prêt à relâcher deux palestiniens
qu'il détient prisonniers cédant ainsi à
l'une des exigences du commando -une
seulement au nicaragua le président
somoza désir bien abandonner le pouvoir
mais il est prisonnier de la garde
nationale qui exige de lui des garanties
au cas où les révolutionnaires
sandiniste prendrait le pouvoir ce qui
semble très probable
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a affirmé
aujourd'hui le directeur de l'institut
espagnol de l'émigration qui vient de se
rendre à managua pour y superviser le
rapatriement des ressortissants
espagnols entre la capitale et
l'aéroport a précisé monsieur escudero
il faut franchir une vingtaine de
barrages de la garde nationale et
quiconque apparaît suspect est fusillé
immédiatement monsieur olivier stirn
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
étrangères vient de rentrer de son long
voyage en extrême orient au cours duquel
il a visité les réfugiés vietnamiens
regroupés dans les camps de malaisie
avant de se rendre au vietnam où il a
rencontré les responsables politiques
monsieur olivier stirn à une semaine de
la conférence de genève sur les réfugiés
conférence organisée par l'onu a fait le
poids de ce douloureux problème avec
gérard saint paul il y à l'aspect
humanitaire qui ne peut pas ne pas nous
préoccuper
il y à l'aspect aussi stabilité de
l'asie qui ne peut pas laisser
indifférent au gouvernement et il faut
toujours se dire dans des cas comme cela
qu'est ce que la france peut faire et ce
qu'elle peut ajouter par son jeu par sa
politique par sa présence pour son
action une carte supplémentaire
vous êtes le seul responsable sur le
plan international à avoir été reçu par
le premier ministre vietnamien mais
certains vendent donc depuis longtemps
alors est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que la position des viet nam ya évolué
sur la question des réfugiés
je crois que les vietnamiens souhaite
que je n'ai soit une réussite
il souhaite que genève march parce
qu'ils sont bien qu'ils sont dans
l'impasse et à la suite de l'entretien
que j'ai eu avec monsieur pham van dong
j'ai peut-être conforter son idée que
genève pouvait
chez et que les peuples européens
comprenez qu'il était nécessaire de
trouver une solution et je pense donc à
l'heure actuelle il y a une possibilité
sur un certain nombre de 10 dès que nous
avons lancé d'arriver à un accord
vous savez que nous avons distingué en
effet les pays de départ qui ont leur
responsabilité
les pays de premier asile de premier
accueil qui ont leurs propres
responsabilités à à mettre en oeuvre et
enfin les pays d'asile qui reçoivent les
réfugiés qui doivent ensuite les insérer
dans leurs propres sociétés autour de ce
canevas il doit y avoir une possibilité
d'entente avec les vietnamiens donc à
tous les bouts de la chaîne
et c est cela qu à genève on essaiera
finalement d'aboutir vous voulez dire
que les vietnamiens serait apparemment
prêts à faire des concessions sur
l'organisation du flot de réfugiés et
peut-être même sur leurs responsabilités
au départ oui notamment sur le contrôle
que l'organisation internationale
pourrait exercer sur le vietnam comme
sur les autres je crois que oui
réponse est oui à l'heure actuelle si ça
ne dégénère pas en tribune politique qui
ne serait pas le sujet et contre
laquelle lesquels la france
s'élèveraient et bien je crois qu'on
peut aboutir à des solutions concrètes
et qu'en effet les vietnamiens sont pris
un certain nombre de concessions homélie
de monseigneur elle changé à l'occasion
de la messe pour la france en ce 14
juillet ce ne sont ni les richesses de
son seul ni ses réserves d'or ou de
devises qui sont le plus grand trésor de
la france ce sont ses enfants
ne sommes nous pas en train de fabriquer
de nouvelles catégories de handicap et
des enfants diminue et affectivement
moralement intellectuellement
malgré la prolongation des études et
spirituellement beaucoup d'entre eux
sont de plus en plus abandonnés il faut
lutter avec opiniâtreté pour empêcher
les enfants d'être exploités et mutilé
par les professionnels de la subversion
idéologique a dit monseigneur elle
changé monsieur benbella désormais
l'autorisation de recevoir tous les
algériens sans restriction c'est ce
qu'il a déclaré hier par téléphone à
europe 1 l'ancien président algérien que
vous voyez sur ces photos prises par
paris match en compagnie de sa femme et
de ses enfants
monsieur ben bella a précisé qu'il ne
pouvait rencontrer d'étrangers ni faire
encore de déclaration politique mais que
cela arriverait sans doute un jour ou
l'autre
monsieur ben bella avait été renversé
par un coup d'état militaire
en juillet 1965 coup d'état organisé par
monsieur houari boumédiène monsieur
mario soares secrétaire général du parti
socialiste portugais a une nouvelle fois
critiqué aujourd'hui la dissolution du
parlement
la décision a été prise hier par le
président de la république portugaise
général et anne heche il y aura donc des
élections législatives anticipées au
portugal ce qui va plonger ce pays dans
une campagne électorale ininterrompue
pendant deux ans quatre élections sont
en effet prévus au portugal d'ici à 1980
grave accident de voiture pour le
coureur cycliste luis ocaña lors de la
journée de repos du tour de france aux
ménuires l'ancien vainqueur du tour a
participé à un gymkhana automobile au
dessus de la station savoyarde
la voiture pilotée par ocaña fait une
chute de 200 mètres dans un ravin et
elle est venue s'écraser dans le lit
d'un torrent luis ocaña souffre de
fractures multiples son coéquipier un
technicien d'antenne 2 jean sarrazin a
été lui aussi grièvement blessé le tour
de france reprendra sa route demain ce
sera la 17e étape les menuires l'alpe
d'huez longue de 166 km 500 bernard
hinault est toujours premier au
classement général avec 2 minutes 45
d'avancé sur hotmail qu et 14 minutes 19
circuits pair avec un escoubet
maintenant la page sportive la suite de
la page sportive de ce journal oui
l'histoire de la coupe davis pour la
france s'arrête cette année au même
stade que l'an passé c'est à dire en
demi-finale de la zone européenne
car nouari moreton n'ont pu réussir à
battre la redoutable équipe de double
tchécoslovaque composée de koné et
schmitt le choix du sélectionneur
français était pourtant judicieux
puisque l'on pouvait imaginer qu après
leur défaite d'hier en simple noah est
mort et on mettrait tout ce qu'ils
avaient dans le ventre pour se venger
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils ont fait mais
le score est là pour prouver que ça ne
suffisait pas 7 5 6 4 5 7 et 6 2
la france est menée par 3 à 0 et les
deux derniers simples demain seront
joués pour l'honneur
à noter que dans les autres rencontres
de coupe davis la grande bretagne se
qualifier aux dépens de l'espagne alors
que la suède mène 2 à 1 devant la
roumanie
borg devait rencontrer demain nastase
pour le point décisif ça risque d'être
assez spectaculaire mais les malheurs
français ne se sont pas arrêtés à roland
garros aujourd'hui à silverstone en
grande-bretagne rené arnoux sur renault
et jean pierre jarier sur tirent elles
n'ont pu terminé que 2e et 3e du grand
prix de grande-bretagne de formule 1 le
vainqueur est un ancien qu'on
n'attendait pas
clay regazzoni le suisse qui courait sur
williams
on attendait renault comme au grand prix
de france
mais renault vous le voyez est arrêté à
son stand avec un problème de roue que
ni le pilote jean pierre jabouille ni
les mécaniciens ne parviendront à
résoudre et tandis qu'à cet instant la
williams de jones tourner en tête de la
course suivi de regazzoni d'arnoult et
des deux ferrari jabouille repart tant
bien que mal pour s'arrêter quelques
tours plus tard
on attendait jones et sa williams
meilleur temps des essais mais vous le
voyez ce n'est plus une voiture que
pilote jones et une cheminée qui dira
sagement rangés au coin du feu au 39e
puis on attend des vagues dans un
sursaut des ligier mais celle de lafitte
abandonnait quelques tours avant que la
ferrari de villeneuve abandonna aussi
restait donc en course pour une victoire
finale la williams de jones la renault
d'arnoult et la tyrrell de jarrier c'est
dans cet ordre qui allait se faire
l'arrivée
rené arnoux ratant la victoire de 24 à
39 ans après plusieurs années de formule
1 et 5 victoires en grand prix
clay regazzoni le suisse avait bien
droit au champagne le classement du
championnat du monde des conducteurs
après cette compétition scheckter est
toujours en tête lille a même augmenté
avec 32 points le deuxième mais
villeneuve 26 points 3e laffitte le
français 24 4e ex-aequo de payet et
rotman
finalement la seule bonne belle et
grande nouvelle est venue cette nuit
d'auckland en nouvelle-zélande où
l'équipe de france de rugby s'est
illustré certains disent déjà d'une
manière historique en battant chez eux
et devant plus de 50000 spectateurs
ravis et pas chauvin eux les fameux all
blacks par le score remarquable de 24 à
19 les français ont marqué entre autres
quatre essais que nous avons le plaisir
de vous faire voir maintenant avec pire
tories
l'histoire la petite manque parfois à
ces rendez vous car ils luttent assez
rudement suffit que ce match là ces
disputes à wellington pour que fut
effacée entre loire et garonne le
souvenir de waterloo
c'est jean michel aguirre qui avaient
ouvert le feu dix minutes après
l'engagement
dix minutes plus tard bill wilson
égalisé 3 à 3 aux velléités offensives
des français les all blacks répliquait
alors sèchement par quelques
regroupements bien senti sur la gauche
et c'est ainsi que sur une ouverture
latérale de taylor bean wilson venus de
l'arrière jaillissent et à travers l'
attaque néo zélandaise et fusées jusqu à
moins d'un mètre de la ligne française
ou d'une pirouette il offrait l'essai à
stuart wilson 7 à 3 38e minute galion
surprend alors au dégagement récupère et
marque set partout 40e minute il reste
quelques secondes à jouer avant la pause
frédéric coste s'échappe au milieu du
terrain et sert à gears qui le flanc
coup de pied à suivre à gears est arrêté
sans ménagement mais caussade poursuit
devance le dernier défenseur adverse et
marque 11 points à 7 ce sera le score à
la mi temps une minute à peine après la
reprise bevan wilson a réduit l'écart à
11 10 sur pénalité consécutive à un
hors-jeu de joinel sanction qui a pour
effet d'émoustiller ledit joinel que
vous avez vu partir sur le regroupement
codorniou la relayer voilà caussade qui
ne doutent plus de rien et sert à
beyrouth 15 points à 10 pour la france
57e minute caussade on vous l'a dit ne
doutent plus de rien il passe le drop
sur service de galions 18 à 10
trois minutes après mes semis contre et
part au pied à beyrouth va récupérer
pour servir caussade ce sera le
quatrième essai français par codorniou
la transformation de caussade alors
qu'il reste à jouer 20 minutes mettra le
point final au bel exploit collectif des
français 24 à 19
ce n'était peut-être face austerlitz
vous pourrez néanmoins répandre à
quiconque vous lira j'y étais voilà un
brave pierre seel secours est à saint
cloud dans la 3e course le prix de la
chapelle c'est first prieur le numéro un
suivi de lido le disent et de dancing
master leucate qui ont ravi les trois
premières places
la combinaison gagnante et dans classe
le dise le 4 qui rapportent dans l'ordre
et pour cinq francs
nous venons de recevoir les rapports à
l'instant et je ne sais pas si on aura
le temps de vous les imprimés sur le
téléviseur mais si je ne me suis pas
trompé dans les multiplications dans
l'ordre pour 5 francs 4292 france 54
1292 francs 50 et dans un ordre
différent toujours pour 5 francs 742
francs 50 oui oui on n'est pas le temps
milliers par cinq mais tout ça c'est la
même chose
attention aux accidents de nuit ils sont
encore plus nombreux pendant les
vacances car beaucoup redécouvre les
joies simples de la promenade à pied ou
de la promenade à vélo mais on oublie
aussi les dangers que cela représente et
pour goûter pleinement ces exercices
écologique il faut penser au danger et
d'abord aux voitures et aux motos la
nuit la visibilité réduite malgré les
phares dans des proportions que piétons
et cyclistes n'imagine pas c'est pour
cette raison que viennent d'être mises
au point des revêtement réfléchissant
spéciaux pour les piétons et pour les
cyclistes
un reportage de claude bertrand
le trafic nocturne et cinq fois moins
important que le trafic de jour pourtant
le tiers des accidents corporels ont
lieu la nuit
et l'on estime actuellement que le
kilomètres effectués de nuit est
généralement deux fois plus dangereux
que celui effectué deux jours c'est la
mauvaise visibilité qui bien sûr est à
l'origine d'un grand nombre d'accidents
il faut savoir qu'en feux de croisement
par exemple un obstacle même un obstacle
claire des visible qu'à 40 mètres et à
60 à l'heure il faut plus de 40 mètres
pour s'arrêter le même obstacle signalé
par un système réfléchissant sera
visible lui à plus de 250 mètres cela
limite considérablement les risques de
collision
actuellement de tels équipements de son
obligatoire que pour les casques de moto
et des poids lourds de plus de 6 tonnes
mais ces bandes réfléchissantes gagne
régulièrement du terrain
déjà huit pays du marché commun ont
adopté des plaques minéralogiques
réfléchissantes
en france pour l'instant leur usage est
encore facultatif mais il pourrait
bientôt se généraliser certains
fabricants s'intéressent également la
bicyclette ainsi des pneus à bandes
réfléchissantes viennent d'être
présentés pour la première fois à
l'exposition mondiale de la sécurité en
bout le jour ces bandes ne se remarquent
pratiquement pas la nuit
voici le résultat
observez la différence ici un vélo
ordinaire dans la circulation et à la
même distance dans les mêmes conditions
d'éclairage
un autre vélo équipée d'éléments
réfléchissant
il s'agit d'un produit composé de
microbilles de verre il y en a plus de
60 millions au mètre carré des
microbilles amalgame est dans une sorte
de résines plastiques transparents qui
renvoient la lumière latéralement
multipliant par plus de 300 le pouvoir
réfléchissant ces bandes réfléchissantes
déjà utilisé pour les combinaisons de
motards font leur apparition également
dans le domaine du vêtement et notamment
du vêtement pour écoliers là encore rien
ne les distingue des autres vêtements
mais la nuit les éléments réfléchissants
améliore considérablement la sécurité
des jeunes piétons
mais attention à pas les confondre avec
les martiens la nuit pour la même chose
amélioration du temps demain surtout au
sud de la loire où il fera beau et chaud
dès le petit matin ce sont donc plutôt
des bonnes nouvelles avec un temps les
gens m'ont rageux aussi en altitude à
23h30 jacques le noir vous présentera le
dernier journal demain c'est gérard
saint paul qui vous présentera toute
l'actualité
bonsoir et merci